the drivers on that particular stretch
of Charleston already speaking out about
the seemingly endless road work there
are Lauren negretti is live from that
part of Charleston hey Lauren have they
started the lane restrictions
good morning not quite yet but you know
I imagine there'll be frustration just
as hard as that tongue twister you had
there but yes we are going to be seeing
these traffic cones out in the streets
here on Charleston as we look at this
stretch of land between Rancho and MLK
so what's happening well that work
includes rehabilitating some sewer
pipelines and seven manholes and then
there's work at MLK with water and sewer
improvements widening widening of
sidewalks and adding traffic signals
just name a few things and like you said
a UNLV Student telling us that she's
anticipating the traffic and changing
her Roots during her morning commute
leaving early like I said other routes
I'm not exactly sure there's like no
really avoiding it because because of
this being all traffic jam everywhere
around this area is going to get much
worse so it's unavoidable
and again it's going to be a year and a
half of some Lane restrictions and
improvements here on Charleston area
don't go anywhere we got more local
reaction coming up and some pedestrian
safety improvements coming to Charleston
for now live in Charles at Charleston
and Rancho Lauren negretti 8 news now
back to you guys Lauren thank you very
much